en 1963 tu es plus empreint de suzy
après toutes ces années de ça faisait
longtemps que vous connaissiez quand
même et tu empruntes pas de quoi se
payer un taxi tu vas en prendre la
camionnette d'un ami maçon et un costume
bleu marine qui était couvert de plaques
quand j'ai vu dans télé 7 jours le
mariage des filles josse ya la
différence la wii ce que je veux
expliquer c'est que toute ma vie moi
j'ai élevé mes enfants ou pas j'espère
que enfin ils le reconnaissent pas comme
des enfants de riches ou des enfants
deux des fils à papa des enfants est par
contre j'ai toujours désiré qu' il n'est
pas les mêmes problèmes que moi quand
j'étais jeune et j'ai souhaité que pour
le mariage de mes enfants
il est l'abondance que j'ai pas pu avoir
pour moi alors à cette époque là tu
galères un peu parce que tu trouve pas
de travail dans l'enseignement
c'est un peu difficile quand 63 par là
et une fois engagé dans un cabaret à 30
bal par jour ce qui était ce qui était
pas beaucoup et là il quelque chose
d'assez touchant c'est quand des pieds
noirs étaient là et qu'il invitait à
leur table tu prenais la consommation la
moins chère parce que tu savais qu'il
n'avait pas beaucoup d'argent et le
patron faisait la gueule non
ça c'est vrai nom mais c'est ça me
rappelle une histoire véridique il
m'était arrivé dans un cabaret à la
table ronde
je j'arrive à sept heures du soir comme
d'habitude et à quelqu'un qui m'a vite à
la table mais il n'y avait personne
n'avait que lui alors je pose ma guitare
et puis me dis qu'est-ce que vous prenez
jeudi un petit café est alors le le
patron du cabaret m'appelle et me dit
c'est comme ça que tu fais marcher les
affaires de la maison ou bien de
demander du champagne pour missing de
l'aca dieu dieu merci il ya vu tout le
monde
et voilà que ils m'en veulent et muffins
une claque
alors moi je réplique je donne un coup
de poing sa femme elle arrive derrière
avec un balai elle me donne un coup de
balai sur la tête
bon moi je récupère ma guitare parce que
je pensais que ma guitare et je sors est
évident que j'ai perdu la place moi
quand tu chantes des fois mon pays
les métropolitains sont assez agressif
avec toi à cette époque là ils disent
d'abord c'est pas ton pays et puis qui
fera plus jamais suer le burnous de sans
faille avait quand même une agressivité
créé points difficiles
alors moi je mettais toujours adieu mon
pays vu mon expérience à ce sujet là je
la mettais toujours à la fin à la fin de
mon spectacle parce que je savais que
derrière je pouvais plus rire chanter
passage finition bagarre générale fait
des fois tu es obligé de quitter la
scène où il sera champion j'ai quitté
mon pays
les retourne dans ton pays frisé ceci
cela alors il y en avait qui 1er mai par
mois j'avais pas besoin de moi je
descendais furtivement dans ma loge je
savais que c'était la fin du spectacle
c'était la bagarre générale alors un
jour il ya un miracle dans ta vie igor
barrère qui fait un cinq colonnes à la
une il veut une séquence sur les pieds
noirs
oui et il te demande de jouer au milieu
de nous il manque d'illustration sonore
c'est incroyable et on me fume à la
mutualité ont fini
le film et ça devait passer le vendredi
d'après n'ont qu'une semaine après et
igor barrère viens boire un coup avec
moi au bar en face de la mutualité je
m'en rappellerai comme si c'était hier
et me dit voilà enrico tout va bien la
séquence s'est très bien passé mais
c'est la séquence qui sautent s'y est
jamais un événement important qui se
passe dans la semaine alors que tous les
jours je lisais le journal pour savoir
pourvu qu'il ait pas quelqu'un qui meurt
pourvu qu'ils aient pas associer les
nationales pour que la séquence mal et
je me rappelle à huit heures du soir ce
avant même le générique c'est ma tête
qu'on voit la division française à cinq
colonnes à la une et avait toute la
famille réunie ma grand-mère moment perd
toute la famille mon père ma mère mes
enfants n'étaient pas mais évidemment
encore ces temps-ci là c'est le succès
parce que c'est immédiat il ya des gens
c'est immédiat ce que j'avais pris le
métro avant d'aller chez
chez ma tante picpus on voir l'émission
mais quand l'émission était passée en
direct à 8h30
j'ai repris de métro pour aller ailleurs
et je ne pouvais plus faire un pas de
ruée mon père était qui était avec moi
m'a dit ça y est mon fils tient une
vedette